yo what's up guys it's marcus brownlee
here from mkbhd and welcome to another
unboxing video this is one this one is
going to be a unibrain unboxing and you
can see the exact product name in the
title of this video
um so basically i'm trying a new little
style format here i moved the camera a
little bit for a smaller box and i'm
trying to sync this audio with my new
microphone so we'll see whether or not
this actually syncs well enough so uh
let's just get right into the box here
this is going to be our unboxing and
first impressions video of this product
so um
yeah let's just get uh right ahead into
the box so here we go
uh let's see here we got a little bit of
tape on it so
obviously break the tape
ah here we go
all right so yeah just tell me if you if
you guys like the new setup i'm trying
to get a little more of a perspective
you know like a down the line
perspective not quite like right over
uh right over the product but uh you can
still get a pretty good idea of what i
see when i'm unboxing the product so
here we go i'm just still trying to
break the tape
so they did put a lot of tape on it was
very good um very good shipping they did
ship i believe let's see on the front
yes it was fedex ground shipping it was
about two day shipping uh from
california it was really really fast
shipping
they did package this up quite a bit um
and the reason i'm guessing that they
package this up so much
is because it's
uh it's pretty good pretty expensive
product they don't want this to get
broken or anything
so yeah let's just get right ahead into
it if i can break break this tape this
pretty
pretty long unboxing i guess here we go
there we go got this uh
all right
we finally finished opening the fx
package and we'll open it up here
and first thing you see is a lot of
bubble wrap and here is the actual
camera itself completely
filled with bubble wrap and we'll take
that out of the bubble wrap here
so i'm just going to put this off to the
side what we have is the firewire cable
itself i will obviously show you guys
that
the software for the firewire camera and
the mini tripod so let me clear this box
out your way guys the box is empty as
you can see
and that was loud so here we go this is
what came in the box if i can
see that glare right there the camera
itself
the software for it okay and the uh the
actual firewire cable now first
impressions of the camera guys sorry
about the mics uh first impressions of
the about the camera it's a lot smaller
than i expected it to be um
from what i can tell it is obviously
there are there is your firewire port
that's where you'll plug it in
to your computer there's where i see
power so you obviously have uh sorry you
have a port here and i put it on the
other side for a whole daisy chain of uh
of these cameras if you do wish for a
multi-camera setup uh you obviously have
this is looking like a little bit of
chrome here uh so we'll see uh what this
software allows us to do these are the
drivers and software that will allow us
to use this as a webcam uh for windows
and linux uh that will allow to allow us
to take uh recordings obviously in vga
yeah we'll get to you guys with the
whole respects and everything the specs
and everything in a review video here's
the uh the mini tripod um
that was shown uh in the the link in the
description has all the specs and
everything the pictures and all that uh
here's what is shown with this miniature
tripod thing here if we can
get it to stand up
just look like a you know a little
tripod you can take the camera very very
simple see on the back you have that
those grooves right there
just gonna hook it up right in there
and that should probably be all we have
to do to hook the camera up to a mini
tripod so that's pretty cool
uh let's see if we can get this on
quickly in a video probably not but i'll
show you guys eventually in a review
video which again comes in one to two
weeks um with from the unboxing of the
product so obviously you guys will get
to see everything that i experienced uh
with this product maybe i'll upload some
test footage so you can see how good the
quality is uh with this actual camera
but yeah if you're looking into a
firewire device or if you're looking
into a camera that doesn't take another
usb port
this one's firewire so this one's going
to be one you're going to want to check
out you know we'll look through the
software this might be more than one
review video anyway guys thanks for
watching this unboxing and first
impressions video if you do like it go
ahead and subscribe there's a lot more
uh a lot more uh tutorials hardware and
software to come
and that's basically it so thanks for
watching this one guys and i'll talk to
you later peace